the elections just a few days away and I
thought it was safe at this point I
thought everyone knows who they're
voting for by now sure that's what I
thought but I've been told in our
audience tonight we have someone who
still hasn't decided who he's going to
vote for please welcome the last
undecided voter in America sir
kurz nice to have you here sir I'm just
I'm just curious what is your name sir
Dan drew Dan drew Dan drew my first name
is Dan my middle name is Andrew and I
couldn't decide which one to go with so
Dan drew it is okay well Dan drew how
could you possibly be undecided between
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump well
they're both so similar
no no they could not be more different
well I disagree but on the other hand I
agree so you agree that they're
different
well that's what they have in common
they're both so different from each
other that they're kind of the same yeah
no they're not no how about this which
of the two parties do you like better
well for parties on the one hand I'm
really excited about my friend Darren's
clambake they got a buddy Neil who's
hosting a jazz murder mystery so now no
I'm talk about political parties who did
you vote for in the last election oh I
am still deciding but I think I'm gonna
write in Vin Diesel let me help you okay
is there one particular issue that's
important to you well I support women
[Applause]
so so then vote for Hillary but a great
way to support women is grabbing them by
the [ __ ]
[Applause]
now now that that's that's not true no
no that's not that's no no how about
this how did you decide what to wear
today let's talk about that well with
the weather being so up and down you
know I didn't know whether to go with
pants or with shorts so I went with this
God's sake come on have you ever made a
single decision in your life just one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You undecided voter thank you dan
dan drew
one of my favorite people ever Brian
McCann right there
you
you